[Music]
[Applause]
good evening I'm Stuart brand
I am from Whole Earth Catalog and it
sort of suffuses the building tonight
I'm also from the long now foundation
another bit of orientation is right over
that way is the long now bar called the
interval right next to greens they'll be
open till 12:30 tonight just in case you
know how to keep partying after the
after-party because they're going to
kick us out of this pier which is run by
Santa Fe Art Institute or Center San
Francisco Art Institute and then carry
on in the wee hours if you want you this
whole event was organized by people I
wanted to introduce Ryan Phelan and
Danica Remy and
Brian's the dannika plans the courier
Danica's development and maker happened
of things and you guys can probably
explain a little bit of the house rules
tonight you need a mic yeah we're miked
sir Thank You Stuart oh and welcome
everyone to this evening's program when
we conceptualize what to do to celebrate
the whole earth 50th we thought what
could be better than for in-depth
conversations now they're kind of
compressed into 25-minute segments but
we tried and we wanted to take four
really important themes from the Whole
Earth Catalog and you have that
information in your brochure today as
well as BIOS on the speakers so we're
gonna try to really run this as promptly
as we can with my co-host here one other
thing I Stewart mentioned the after
party and just want to make sure
everyone is thinking about making plans
to come over at the end this evening
enjoying the rest of the alumni that
have been honestly partying all day next
door so Danica what else and then I'd
like to bring the volume down a little
bit and remind everybody that we have a
hundred and forty three issues of whole
earth coevolution quarterly and the
catalogs on display and it's quite
amazing to walk the line from 1968 all
the way to 2002 and we stopped
publishing and so I hope you'll enjoy
the art the covers and the conversations
about where you were when you read one
of those or what you were doing at the
year that those were published I
encourage all of you to a hashtag
haulers 50th and hashtag stay foolish
and stay hungry and take no flashes in
the theater please but when you get into
the after party and we encourage photos
all over the place so please enjoy and
hashtag sfa i our host for this evening
San Francisco Art Institute who have
graciously given us the atrium next door
so with that with that see you guys in a
few minutes I'll be back at the end of
the program I'm just here one more
second
introduced the first perspective giver
on things there's all these faux images
of birth you know that's a photograph
then and that thing's just a fun ball
but it's best to hear from somebody
who's seen it ah the Apollo nine
astronaut rusty Schweickart
[Applause]
Thank You Stuart Ryan and and Danica
this is the 50th anniversary of the
Whole Earth Catalog it also is the 50th
anniversary of human beings seeing that
whole earth with their own eyes in in
the blackness of space it's the 50th
anniversary especially for me of the
Apollo program and not only do we
celebrate the intersection of the Whole
Earth Catalog and the Apollo program
today but 50 years ago was the same the
intersection was there 50 years ago it
all started the Whole Earth Catalog was
Stuart and and the whole earth with
Stuart stoned one day and writing this
this historic thing why haven't we seen
you know a photograph of the whole earth
and of course Stuart then went around
wearing a sandwich board and we all know
the story
I've always chuckled at that but Stuart
was not the first person who had the
idea Fred Hoyle made this wonderful
statement back in 1948 and I think this
is the essence of what we're really
talking about today human beings have
now had that view and the first people
who had it were got to go back on their
first people who had that vision were
the Apollo 8 crew as they went out
around the moon in at Christmas time in
1968 and this is what Bill Anders saw
when he looked out the window the real
blackness of space not with the earth in
the view or the Sun but just the Stars
and that made a huge impression on him
this is a slightly different picture
when he looked at it at another time
without the Sun and the earth shine on
the moon the moon interfered with that
and he
really understood the blackness of space
three orbits later they went around the
first three orbits going backward around
the moon and it was pretty boring
watching the craters but they turned
around on the fourth orbit and this was
what the the sight they saw coming over
the horizon this is the first time human
eyes had seen this beautiful planet
contrasted against the the greys of the
moon and the blackness of space to me
this was the moment of cosmic birth the
moment when humans first left the womb
of Mother Earth and moved out into the
universe this is historically the moment
we're living it now
that's a moment of 10,000 years perhaps
for how long now or perhaps a few dozen
years but this was this is the important
element we are born out of the womb of
Mother Earth it is only as human life is
born out of the womb that it begins to
occur she ate love and begin to take
care of its mother and we as we move out
into the cosmos must both love and look
back at and take responsibility for the
mother from which we emerged you'll hear
that theme again and again so this is
our responsibility and we must accept
this responsibility as we move out into
space thank you
[Applause]
Thank You rusty I'd like to invite
Stephanie Mills to the stage I'm so
sorry Kevin Kelly excuse me
no panic Stephanie Kevin Kelly and I
just want to say Kevin Kelly came on the
scene in 1984 almost by mail order
Stewart was in a panic he was in the
thick of trying to do the whole ear
software catalog and he'd been
corresponding and exchanging columns
with Kevin and Kevin came to our rescue
and the rest is history
thank you so much so I want to talk
about the other part of what you see on
the cover of the Whole Earth Catalog
what you see of course at first is the
whole earth and that cosmic overview
that resi just talked about like almost
transcendent view that you get of our
own life but beneath that on the cover
anyway is the second news and I think
the second revelation which is access to
tools which is I think almost as
important as the overview of the whole
earth access to tools connotates
that you're going to do something with
tools and what we normally do with tools
is make things and so what I want to
talk about is that connection between
the whole earth catalogue and the maker
movement that we've seen today and it
was a very direct line I believe what
the catalog was being used for and a lot
of people was not necessarily trying to
giving him a new perspective on the
environment or the planet but they
needed to know how to dig a well they
were going to go back to the land and
they needed to figure out how to build a
roof or they wanted to try to homeschool
their kids and they wanted some
suggestions about curriculum it was
about how to do stuff how to make things
how to make things happen and that
how to was what the catalog was selling
so to speak in the very beginning and it
made a huge difference I think many
people can testify the fact that the
whole earth care will change our lives
and they change lives because it told
them how to do things that they didn't
even know that they wanted to do told
them how to do things they wanted to
know how to do but it most importantly
opened up this gate way to possibilities
about things that didn't even know that
they wanted to do and I think that
enlargement of the possibility space the
tools bring is one of the great nudges
that the whole earth catalogue made to
our culture it kind of opened up the
possibility space and so people like
myself who encountered it for the first
time said we met you can actually you
know build your own house you can
actually buy dynamite and blow up a
boulder you can actually figure out how
to have bees in your backyard that's all
possible I didn't even think about that
before and now I have that possibility
because I know that these tools exist I
know this information exists and so I
think that was this AHA that the culture
had where it was taking a long American
tradition of doing things on your own
making stuff in basements anybody who
grew up on a farm would realize that
there were makers the farmers are makers
by necessity but there's two things that
were different this time one was this
enlargement about the kinds of things
that you can learn how to do yourself it
wasn't just fixing farm machinery it was
learning how to pan for gold it was
learning how to program a programmable
calculator it was exerting how to knit
in an old-fashioned way that had died
out all these things were now something
that you could learn how to do not just
the things that your grandfather or
grandmother knew and secondly I think
it's sped up accelerated the rate of
learning and it accelerated it in a very
major way where before if you wanted to
find out how to do something
it was almost impossible to connect with
that correct information libraries were
very very small book stores were
pathetically under stocked there was
simply no way to find out how to do
these things we we don't really even
remember how bad it was
and so this acceleration has only gained
speeds and so now we have the extension
of the Whole Earth Catalog which was the
web and then we had an extension of that
web which is YouTube and I think as we
look at this movement to take tools and
to make things and to expand our
possibilities I think of no better
example of the way in which the
acceleration has happened other than the
millions of YouTube videos of people who
have taken what they know and they're
sharing it and telling other people how
to do what they have learned to do and
that acceleration is really really
underappreciated right now it's it's
massively important massively faster
than any way we could have imagined and
I think a lot of the stuff that we're
seeing worldwide in terms of people
making things starting things making
things happen has been because the
access to tools that the whole earth
initiated has accelerated and expanded
in the form of YouTube and has gone on
to really change what we think about as
culture and as an indication of the
importance of YouTube I want to
introduce the next speaker who is a
YouTube maker star simone yurts is a
maker innovator creator inventor who has
a massive youtube following and she
began a channel about what she called
shitty robots she has a sense of humor
she's an entertainer as well and she'll
be up here to tell you about serve this
next phase of the maker movement simone
hello thank you so much Kevin
my name is Simone and yeah I'm a maker
and inventor I kind of go between the
two titles depending on what mood I'm in
I like inventor because it makes it
sound like I'm in a cartoon but I'm
definitely a maker and part of the maker
community but maybe more so in maker
entertainment and I run a YouTube
channel where I build different projects
mostly robotics or that's what I'm
mostly known for shitty robots and
whenever somebody doesn't hasn't seen
them and I say that I build shitty
robots they're like don't talk yourself
down and I'm like no but they're
supposed to be shitty that's the whole
point so here just to show you some
examples here's an alarm clock that I
made to help me wake up in the morning
this video on different platforms has
been seen around 80 million times which
probably makes me the person on all the
planet Earth that most people have seen
getting slapped in the face for the
rubber hand and I'm not sure what type
of legacy that is but I'll take it
here's a lipstick girl bot that I made
because makeup is hard
and here's a robot that I made to help
me serve soup this one takes a little
while so it's probably gonna eat up the
rest of my time here for the intro but
let's wait for the punchline maybe I'm
more in the business of keeping a
straight face more than anything but
yeah without more further ado let's
bring Kevin Kelly back out
[Applause]
maybe we should progress the slide or
maybe we should just keep this it's it's
a pretty it's a good frame so our
purpose now is to kind of think about
the role of making in the world the role
of being able to allow people to make
new things and one of the other
attendees here tonight is Neil
Gershenfeld who runs a Fab Lab and one
of his points is that the seemingly
direction that we're going to is will
get to the point where the tools will be
so available and cheap that basically
it's some point in most people's lives
they will make something just like today
most educated middle class lives people
will write something you know writing in
the past a thousand years ago we'd been
a almost impossible thing for most
people to do because they weren't even
literate and they had very little
occasion to have to write anything now
writing is a common thing that everybody
does and I think making is headed in
that same direction you won't make most
of the things in your lives but you'll
make something at some point in your
life and I wonder if you have any kind
of feelings about whether you felt that
you are a maker now because the tools
are easier or what why are you making
things and you know would you have made
them ten years ago well ten years ago I
was
danger and not really interested in
robotics robotics um yeah I mean I I
think definitely I so badly want the
maker movement to be this kind of
antidote to consumerism and be an
alternative to or instead of buying
things you make things and instead of
throwing things away you fix things but
I've kind of been looking at the pattern
of how I'm making and I realize it's
mostly just me buying a bunch of
materials and tools and it's like it's
it's in some way it's easy for it to
become a little bit like a gear sport
and I like makers faces are a good
compromise and that where it's like oh
we can give people access to tools and
access to making without having to get
all these expensive gear but yeah I
don't know of course tools getting
cheaper like they're being raspberry
PI's for $3 or $5 that's I mean it's
it's huge it's such a game-changer you
can take the risk of making mistakes
when you're not gambling huge
investments and did you when you were
growing up you said you were teenager
you weren't thinking about robotics when
did you have start thinking about
robotics we need to kind of realize oh
my gosh I even I could be making robots
it's it was honestly not until I saw
another woman give a lecture on robotics
and she was she was this hardware hacker
and I remember seeing it cuz like I grew
up with a really geeky older brother who
would pick computers apart and who would
program and stuff like that but I was
always like no that's not for me and it
wasn't until I saw another woman that I
could kind of project myself onto that I
was like wow if she can do that then I
can do that too and it suddenly was like
just this like what are you saying
curtain fall down there was a aha moment
maybe that's them Simone grew up in
Sweden until very recently so I was yes
do you not say that oh god dammit I miss
up idioms all the time it's it's how
people catch me but I asked you I was
like you were like what do you want me
to say when I enter you and I was like
tell people I'm Swedish
like no but it's just nice to know that
I might mess things up yeah the curtain
fell down from my from my ignorant face
and I saw the world of making and I as a
woman can do this too so do you have any
any sense of like do you wish you had
access to more tools do you what would
you need if you could wave a magic wand
to kind of make your life richer in
terms of making things is it cheaper
tools more tools more time more
information honestly at this point it's
just more time like that's definitely
the limiting factor and it gets to this
weird point when you're like I mean I
started my youtube channel three years
ago and I was just like doing these
projects are fun and I started putting
them online and it's like grows to this
point when you kind of start a company
and you're like running more of a
business where it's like I don't have
time to make things anymore
and so I really wish that I had more
time that's the biggest so we should
make a machine that made more time right
[Laughter]
that's actually I mean I feel like a lot
of people have tried to attempt that but
I'll give it a go but I'm kind of
interesting interested in like when did
the word maker come around do you
remember when people started identifying
themselves as makers cuz now is
definitely a thing where people like I'm
a maker I actually think it was a
marketing term devised by Dale Daughtery
who worked for Tim O'Reilly and wanted
to do a magazine that was about like
cool tools about how to make stuff and
they he came up with this idea of maker
and that seemed like like wired it was a
really good name it was really short a
few letters in it and it kind of took
off so there was the you know the Maker
Faire and and I didn't really kind of
talk about that lineage but I think it
was to me was no accident that the the
Maker Faire and the maker movement and
the maker magazine that kind of all came
out of San Francisco I think
has been a long trend trajectory of
[Music]
making your own things as something that
was sort of honorable and I think there
is a connection between the maker
mindset and Silicon Valley this this
willingness to do something on your own
and that was again the whole earth
catalogue motif which was do-it-yourself
start your own thing do your own thing
and that has transitions in the maker
and I think it was at the beginning of
Make Magazine yeah I really like the
term maker because as a youtuber people
also call you a creator so I'm both the
maker and a crater which makes me sound
like I'm God also really humble humble
God so so I think and I I don't know
about you but I spend many hours a night
watching youtube videos about how to
make things I learned how to weld that
way I learned how to electroplate metals
by watching YouTube clips and it's
something I could not have learned just
reading a book and I don't know do you
find the same thing are you learning how
to do things on YouTube yeah I mean you
turn to YouTube all the time it's yeah
it's it's so readily available and it's
it's just cuz and I feel like there's I
mean of course it's like the issue
quality control like how do you trust
the people making these videos but then
you just read the comments and there if
somebody is an expert and they're doing
it wrong like the first comment is gonna
be something like actually it's called
XYZ yeah so are you finding that people
watch you to learn how to make things
no I'm that would be really scary
yeah but I'm utterly uneducated a choice
that I made when I started in my channel
cuz I was like I started building these
things as a way to learn and
and a lot of people do tutorials around
especially around robotics and
electronics and I was like I'm not in a
position to teach people like that's not
I'm a hobbyist like I'm a happy hobbyist
who happen to get a big audience and I
think there's a lot of people who do
such a great job of tutorial so I guess
I could get away with saying that it
might be inspiring yeah I mean that's
something maybe somebody watches it and
they're like yeah I also want to build
stuff or if she can do that I can do
better it started as a compliment and
then ended as an insult I really like it
I mean to me like engineering and
approaching engineering is really
daunting because there's a lot of like
it's it's a scary process it's something
that's really scary to teach yourself
and to take on and also in engineering
there there's a lot of like kind of
expert culture and for me setting out to
build shitty robots was a way to kind of
like deflate that and be like hey I'm
not setting out to be an expert and
people can criticize me for building
this project but I was just doing it for
fun
I just feel like people you kind of want
to avoid a culture where people are
scared of doing making mistakes yeah I
think that's one of the the benefits of
your videos is that you allow yourself
to to make mistakes you you you sort of
celebrate and sense things that don't
work as a means to inspire other people
to you know make things that do work I
hope so yeah or maybe it's just this is
the start of the idiocracy this is how
it goes so one of the things that I'm
really interested in is sort of where
this goes into the future and how the
maker movement how doing it yourself
might continue to evolve and where it
might go in another 10 years or 20 years
have you ever thought about well if
things continue the way they do and this
world of makers and creators in ten
years it'll be like what do you have a
vision I think it's more that like we
won't want to the same I mean now in
school or in education there's so much
about learning a thing and what I hope
to see more is learning to learn because
now it's like things are evolving so
fast you can't really know everything or
be an expert in a field because things
are evolving really really fast so it's
like you just have to know how to find
information and how to figure it out and
how to solve problems so I hope that
that's like and that goes beyond the
maker movement that goes can be on
everything but just what it means to be
human these days yeah I would agree
wholeheartedly I think that the central
curriculum of any kind of say high
school level graduation would would be
knowing how you knowing how to learn and
specifically knowing how I learned best
knowing how each person to graduate with
knowing how they learn the best in all
the different situations and that super
skill of learning how to learn and
optimize for yourself so that you knew
exactly how you learn best would be
really the thing that you want to
graduate with how do you learn best well
you know I think the thing about it is
is that it's actually I've been
searching and I have not found a single
curriculum that would teaches you how to
learn how to learn and none that teaches
you how to optimize your own learning
and so we don't know I mean I don't know
how I learn best I would really like to
know that but I think that is the meta
skill that is a super skill that you
would like people to graduate with and I
think would take a lot of work I think
would take a lot of teaching testing
trying things and training to be able to
do that so it's not something you could
absorb by itself I think it would be
something illiterate like a literacy
that you would have to be taught and you
graduate with and I think that would be
the thing that that schools should pride
themselves on teaching and really though
anything you need to do when you
graduate so instead of having like what
are they calling Myer Briggs
personality categories you have learned
our categories exactly right and you're
like you're this type of learner people
have are all different types of
learnings and so you still have to learn
how to learn different situations but
you would understand how you learn best
in those different situations and that
would be the ultimate maker skill what
is the thing you learn recently in
welding I've been playing around with
electro nickel plating and then I'm
learning teaching myself how to edit
video and I graduated from iMovie to
Premiere Pro so and how about you what
have you learned recently
whatever you oh I did not expect to get
that question bounce back at me you know
whatever I learn recently um I mean I'm
learning I'm starting a product
development country companies so I'm
learning a lot about manufacturing and
there's a lot to learn about it but I
really I really want to learn welding I
have a welding station I have a fume
extractor I have a welding hood I just
need to learn yeah I also have a fight
fire extinguisher it's - fire
extinguisher no I think I think that's
again that's the inspiration that that
for me the whole earth catalogue is that
you can learn new things you have these
possibilities and you know I you go
through the pages and you're like oh
that you can do this you can you'll
preserve skulls with with bleaching
whatever I think I didn't know you could
do that
now you can and so right people are
gonna take this to heart or is it just
your own skull it's like a new beauty
trend like yeah yeah really bright
skeleton yes yeah it's you have to use
hydrogen peroxide that's the secret
don't use bleach huge hydrogen peroxide
everybody taking notes
so anyway do you have anything else you
what would your advice be for people who
are making things in 30 seconds yes
really cherish your enthusiasm we're
really good at teaching people how to be
Duty driven and be diligent about doing
things and I've noticed that for myself
a much better fuel is if I'm genuinely
excited about something and that's when
I really get done but it requires a
lot of taking care of yourself and
making sure that you have the right
parameters so just figure out figure
that out that's rubbish advice not
quotable at all that's Swedish that will
work already what about you I think the
thing is is beginning with failure I
mean count on the fact that you're gonna
fail and that failure is to be accepted
and actually welcomed so the first
things you do second things even the
third things aren't going to work and
that's just perfectly okay and you
should really embrace that so make stuff
that fail yeah all right
thank you Kevin thank you see mom Danica
and next up I'd like to ask Howard
Rheingold to come up to the stage I'd
originally met Howard and I originally
met Howard in 1991 when for a moment
someone thought I could be the publisher
of whole earth of which I knew I could
never be so I've been very grateful that
Howard took that leadership so 1968 was
the year that not only did the whole
earth catalogue first appear but it was
the year I graduated from college and
headed out into the world things are
pretty up now but 1968 was was
kind of apocalyptic
and and I think that that like probably
most of the people in this room who are
old enough I I carried that first whole
earth catalogue from place to place with
me for quite a while it was both an
aspirational guidebook to how I might
design a life for myself but also it was
an inspiration and an invitation to try
to repair what was going on in the world
and a strong sense that that you get
from looking at the video or looking at
those old catalogs and that there was a
community of people who were doing this
I didn't really join the enterprise for
about 20 years when I got involved with
the well and started spending an
inordinate amount of time hanging out
online with what my wife called my
imaginary friends who many of whom are
out here
and I didn't really think about
community until I was challenged but by
Kevin now Kevin tried to get me to write
for whole earth by but I couldn't afford
to do that I was trying to make a living
as a writer and he only paid $250 so he
would come to my house and provoke
arguments and he challenged me to
explain to him why I thought the well
was like a community and then he said
what you just said write that down I'll
pay you $250 so that that that made the
same enterprise seem a lot easier that
article was published in 1987 it took
some years to get a contract write a
book about people communicating through
computer networks because editors kept
telling my agent that only
electrical engineers would would want to
do that and they wouldn't sell very many
books almost immediately after writing
the book I started getting a lot of
flack from critics and academics and
scholars and I didn't aspire to be a
social scientist or a scholar I was just
trying to write a book and make a living
as a writer but immediately the
criticism came that well these aren't
really communities and in fact you're
degrading the idea of community so I
started thinking about that but I didn't
really drill down on it until about 2005
when I started teaching college students
about virtual community and what's now
called social media and looking into it
I discovered that a sociologist came up
with 95 different definitions of
community that you could find in the
social science literature so we can
define community but it's not a
definition that everybody is going to
accept and it's not a an objective
definition that that exists in the world
outside of our our wrestling with what
community is and in many senses it's a
projective test about our hopes and and
fears about the way our lives
and the world seems to be changing
largely because of the advent of
communication technologies and in fact
sociology started when Ferdinand tönnies
in the 19th century started writing
about the way life was changing when
people moved from villages to cities and
from norms and customs to contracts he
called it oh my mind's gone blank on it
does anybody remember what those words
are
oh so back then it was modernity that
was happening and now of course the
changes that come in our cities in our
social lives through communication
technologies are so much more global and
are happening so much faster and we're
discovering that there are all kinds of
great communities out there and there
are also Nazis and in cells and
terrorists and gamergaters community
seems to have this aura of being this
nice thing that used to exist but
doesn't anymore but it's something that
keeps changing and people who don't have
nice ideas can have communities too so
there's more to say about this but
fortunately we have some time to to talk
about it so I'm going to invite chip
Conley to come up and talk for a minute
[Applause]
I'm doing my best to keep up with
Howard's
wardrobe pretty impressive colors and I
just before I get started I say to
Stuart when I started my first company
Jawad Aviv hotels 32 years ago the first
thing I had in my business plan was
start cheap small and local which I
learned from you from Hollerith catalog
thank you so I'm gonna take us back
actually a lot longer Ivan took us back
to 1910
eeehm Forster wrote a book Howards End
started the book with an epigraph only
connect but what you don't know is
probably is a year earlier he had
written a book or written a short story
called the machine stops and machine
stops was all about how in essence it's
basically where we hurted hate to be
honest with you it's how the machine
actually became the intermediary in
terms of our connections so almost
exactly that same time Emile Durkheim
wrote a book and and coined a phrase
coined a term collective effervescence
he studied religious pilgrimages and say
how communities came together and what
happened when communities came together
around a certain mission is that their
ego evaporated and a communal joy
emerged
well I've experienced that at Burning
Man for about 25 years and I'm on the
board and I as I spent more time
imagining collective effervescence of a
community I spent a few years created a
website called fest 300 that featured
the 300 best festival oh thank you
featured the 300 best festivals in the
world my job was to be the most
interesting person in the world to go
around to all these festivals and
experience collective effervescence in
community now I was doing this at
exactly the time that URLs we're awash
in them and yet people needed this IRL
experience the in real life experience I
saw that as a boutique hotel you're in
San Francisco where I connected our
who come to our hotels with locals we
call it the golden gate greeter program
where we connected locals with people
visiting the city and then for the last
five and a half years I've been at
Airbnb with helping the young founders
steer the rocket ship and in charge of
community globally for Airbnb for the
four of those five and a half years and
my role was to actually help bring an
online community the especially our host
community together in person on occasion
and we did it exactly at Fort Mason our
first host community event in-person
night in 2014 1,500 hosts here 6,000
hosts in in Paris a year later and then
20,000 hosts a year later from 110
countries and the thing that I noticed
more than anything was the idea that IRL
and URL are not at odds
you know the idea of connecting with
people online and then figuring out how
to meet in person so we are mirror
neurons could dance together which is
something that's hard to do online is
what we have and if you you know for the
future and so the last thing I'm going
to say before I bring Howard back out is
I want you to close your eyes for a
moment close your eyes I'm gonna do the
same and imagine when you hear the word
community what is meaningful to you
around that word what does it conjure up
for you what is it that community does
what community do you think of that
actually brings a smile to your face and
a spirit to your soul and as you think
about that community ask yourself is it
in real life or is it URL and
with that I'm gonna ask you to open your
eyes and Howard come on back on stage
and we're gonna we're gonna arm wrestle
about virtual versus in person hi all
right go mine shaft and ghazal shaft
well you know you've you've had that
jacket since the mid-80s if I'm not
mistaken correct yo I wore it because it
was in the film yeah exactly so it still
looks good and Cheers so talk about we
got a community here in this room and
they're in real life well I think I
would like to ask you is what do you
think about URL versus IRL is it a
versus or is it an and is you know what
do you think well one one of the reasons
I felt that that the well was very
community like and it's something that I
think all of us still experience is that
we were able to connect with people that
that we either shared an interest with
or sparked some some some kind of
attraction that that we might not
otherwise have connected with and you
know many of those people remain
imaginary friends some of them are on
the other side of the world but there's
there is an almost kind of gravity that
draws people together so I'd say that
maybe more than half of the people that
I know now our people that I originally
met online so and you know you mentioned
Burning Man when I
I guess 1994 in 1995 when a lot of
techie started going to Burning Man I
remember people remarking that it
wouldn't be possible without email and
that a lot of what brought that
community together just had to do with
the infrastructure for connecting people
when I started thinking about what what
was unique about this new computer
mediated communication I thought well
you can connect with people
that that you want to connect with even
if you didn't know them and it's a
many-to-many medium but at times looking
at social media and how we see these
tribes who then are fighting with
another tribe and and frankly don't have
misses necessarily civil decorum in
terms of how they communicate how do we
solve for that I mean I eat funny other
fact is it's the 50th anniversary of
Mister Rogers neighborhood and like back
then you know yeah let's I saw that duck
I flew from Miami to San Francisco I had
a speech in Miami this morning strangely
enough and I flew today and I watched
that film on the way back and it's
interesting to look back to that era 50
years ago mr. Rogers and the
neighborhood the community and there was
almost like a civil decorum that goes on
why is it that we've so fallen off that
path in the virtual or the digital world
well I don't think I don't think we're
having I don't think people have become
more calls coarse and vulgar and mean I
think it's just more easily visible to
us now and you know this idea that
communication technologies are changing
community not for the better is not a
new idea of Robert Robert Putnam wrote
about Bowling Alone and the decline of
social capital and America and what he
correlated it with and he tried
correlating it with everything else race
relations women entering the the
workforce and he would he he ultimately
correlated it with was the the rise of
people watching television all the time
so well there are a couple of things
that that I think are important one of
them is the public sphere and I'd like
to talk about that but I think the other
thing we need to talk about is that
community is not this thing that used to
exist or that exists in an ideal form
it's something that we should wrestle
with and particularly since things are
changing more rapidly for what Tunney's
was involved with was it
suddenly changed the way people had
lived in their villages for thousands of
years now we get that kind of epical
changes on a decade basis I mean I
recently I recently found out I have
prostate cancer less than four weeks ago
and I was able to connect with a
community of its intermediate stage so
it's you know it's something that's
concerning in the past I'm not sure if I
didn't have an online way to actually
research it and then listen to people
who actually have had it similar stage
to where I am and then actually go out
and communicate with them and I have all
of that as an experience in the last
four weeks and then frankly to have the
IRL experience as well as know oh here's
a meet-up of people who are talking
about that to me it's a it's a it's
glorious that I have two different paths
to actually have that kind of experience
that helps me feel like I'm not alone
well you know when in fact in 1986 one
of the things that that really coalesced
the idea of community around the well
was when when Phil Katz son came down
with leukemia and we created an online
support group overnight
now there's Jillian's of online support
groups 1986 that was a new thing so that
was 1986 but nine years ago I came down
with cancer and I needed people to drive
me to treatments every day and many many
people from the well including Phil cat
who drove over from Berkeley to pick me
up and drive me to a radiation treatment
and then you know you're kind of
isolated and and terrified and being
able to connect with people online was
really important also I started a tumblr
about it a because I didn't want to tell
the same story to every person who asked
me how I was doing and and be because
that had been my way of connecting with
people and it was a way to get out a lot
of these feelings that
your oncologist doesn't want to talk to
you about so you know that's the bright
side of things is that people who need
to connect with someone because they're
in trouble can find a lifeline so I I
want to go back to the decorum thing and
the civility thing did you think that
that they did does that somehow cleanse
itself over time or are there some
elements of either rules or social mores
that actually start to define how we
create community or connect in a civil
way amongst communities online well my
personal opinion about it is that
network of people who communicate online
are not necessarily a community and one
of the things that signals the formation
of community is that they begin to
enforce norms so there's a lot of bad
stuff going on online now there was a
lot of bad stuff going online all the
time now there's just a lot more people
online and when I started writing the
book the thought that occurred to me
that I thought about a lot was what's
the most important thing about this
communication medium if as we believe a
lot of people are going to be using it
and that brought me to the idea of the
public sphere that political
philosophers had been talking about that
I didn't had not known about until I
asked and it's the idea that democracy
is not just about voting for your
leaders it's not having a population who
are free enough to communicate and
educated enough to have conversations
that form public opinion and that public
opinion would influence policy and
there's a lot of bugs in that
particularly these days and I'd have to
say that my the critical uncertainty was
will the public sphere be improved by
people communicating online will
democracy be improved will individuals
have more freedom and I have to say that
I don't feel very optimistic or
hopeful about that now but the
difference between optimism and and and
hopefulness is that hope is a choice and
so I think one of the things that
everybody in this this room can do is to
think about how might we improve the the
public sphere I don't know that you can
do it in a top-down way and I do think
that education is a great deal to do
with it and our schools our educational
institutions certainly aren't meeting
that challenge so when I asked people to
close their eyes did you close your eyes
no I didn't think so
so when you think a community do you do
you go straight to the digital side of
it or do you actually think of an IRL
community and in real life community as
well well you have to understand then I
spent most of my life as a writer and a
writer is in a room alone which I think
was why the it became so attractive to
me to be able to communicate with with
people online so I'm probably not the
the best person to talk to about that
but dealing with my students who live
immersed in this world they have many
more choices of the kinds of people that
they can associate with and the kinds of
communal discussions that they can
participate in then then I had her my
generation had so I think this is a
there's a huge amount of freedom but
again the uncertainty is who knows what
to do about it people stumble into
places would be nicer if they could be
more prepared any last thoughts
questions comments well the the last
discussion about learning I think has a
great deal to do with what some of the
positive potential of life online is I
started calling my my
classes co-learning communities and i
started calling my students Koller nur's
and that sounds kind of superficial but
it really had an effect on them and one
thing that the the the media that we
have now provides is educational
opportunities that we've never had
before you unless you were really a
dedicated autodidact you really had to
go to school to learn things for
thousands of years but now I would say
if if you ask 14-year old how would you
learn to play the ukulele or configure a
web server they would say well I go to
youtube and search on it don't read the
comments but there's a lot that you can
comment I've learned that one if you've
learned how to not pay attention to the
ugly stuff there's a lot that we can
learn together I think the one thing
that's sort of lacking kevin was talking
about learning about learning how do we
learn to be learners in community with
all of these tools with with search and
Wikipedia and YouTube and and all of the
social media for connecting with each
other if we're not the teacher what if a
group of students wants to learn
together I think that we're going to see
that develop so I'll wrap up by just
saying I think I am my experience in
moving from being a localized boutique
hotel your'e with a bunch of hotels all
in the region to becoming a hospitable
hospitality called the Guru and the
company around hospitality and community
and to have that be in 192 countries
taught me that it is definitely not a
versus it's a it's an and it's not you
know URL versus IRL that the opportunity
for the web and for the connection with
others and the efficiency of how you can
find the people who can become your
tribe
is beautiful online and then what it
affords is the opportunity to create
that community in person when you can
again if the person who you really
relate to the most is in Iceland you
know you may not see them all that often
but I really have found on a personal
level with this Airbnb community the
idea that you can actually create a
sense of passion with people and then
give yourself that opportunity to find
the people locally that you can actually
have the face to face in real life
experience with because both of them
frankly I think both of them speak to
our humanity the desire to actually
discover people and the desire to deepen
a connection with someone which from at
least from my perspective happens more
easily in person I would just add one
thing at the end it's an advice for for
people online which is I think one thing
that would improve life online a great
deal is that if a UH norm developed that
it's okay to throw trolls out that um
the First Amendment says Congress shall
make no law not let's let this jerk slap
people around in my living room and and
the number of people who will leave
because they're offended by censorship
is a fraction of the number of people
who never you never hear from because
they don't want to stick their head up
and have something thrown at it I'm not
happy note we're done Thank You Howard
[Applause]
Thank You Howard Thank You Chuck well
we've gone from do-it-yourself learning
and communities both virtual and in
reality it wouldn't be a whole earth
event without thinking about the
environment there's no one better to
bring up that discussion and Stephanie
Mills Stephanie when Stephanie graduated
from Mills College at a very young age
she became the leading spokeswoman for
the environment and in 1980 I went on to
work at coevolution as part of the staff
team when he just did you're alive right
here Thank You Ryan
gratitude to mother earth gratitude to
Stuart and Ryan and their colleagues for
realizing this event gratitude to
Stephanie Feldstein for her partnership
tonight the image was taken this summer
in a stand of old-growth white pine
saved in 1973 from the chainsaws by a
small group of thoughtful committed
citizens
the plants are bunchberry and Canada
Mayflower gratitude to all those beings
Stuart master of compressed utterance
asked for five minutes on the last and
next half centuries more than a tweet
less than a tome fifty years is an
eyeblink yet despite many good-faith
efforts at every level to prevent waste
and ruin the growth of industrial
civilization has ravaged the earth
depleting soil water and biodiversity
contaminating the oceans and the
atmosphere in 1968 Paul in an air lick
dropped the Population Bomb
there were about 3.5 billion of us then
over seven billion now contraceptive
means improved while political
calculation cultural conservatism and
patriarchy hampered their widespread
adoption sixties temblors of
revolutionary change cracked a few
foundations in 1972 from the Club of
Rome we got a world systems model
forecasting industrial civilizations
inescapable limits to growth in 1974
Congress heard of M king Hubbert curve
mapping the limits to oil production the
end times for a petroleum driven global
infrastructure big business as usual has
continued critical thresholds have been
crossed a late-breaking discussion of D
growth is underway but yet to reach a
wide audience a half century ago we
thought about living more responsibly
access to tools enlivened possibilities
of household homestead village and
neighborhood self-reliance there was
hope of stalling the apocalypse
juggernaut there still may be while it
coevolution quarterly best magazine that
ever lived I also worked on the next
hole Earth Catalog its extensive reviews
of essential means like hand tools and
simple machines how-to books for scores
of timeless crafts a spectrum of advice
on farming and gardening and astute
reporting on appropriate technologies
remain durable goods where I live quite
a few young hand makers digital natives
cherish the catalogue for its can-do
spirit and for arraying the physical and
conceptual tools they wield they're
flourishing while reducing their
dependence on brittle systems and long
lines of supply
what's coming possibilities I hope for
probabilities to dread possible a
renewed stirring of love for the earth
respect for and reciprocity with all
beings both love of place and interest
in nature stem from our longtime past
although these days they court struggle
in grief
along with authentic connection they've
got survival value bellied botanists and
bird nerds fraud counters and foragers
begin as kids they're the ones who grow
up to be the Rachel Carson's and EO
Wilson's the water protectors at
Standing Rock maybe you've got such a
one hope so in the chaos of our moment
perhaps a new understanding is imminent
a fundamental change of heart is needed
and there are harbingers from the eco
Pope to ecological restoration
esteverena milles of our kind are
supposed to be uniquely moral actors
now's the time to prove it if our
descendants are to inhabit a whole earth
after this collision with ecological
limits we had Brett best embrace virtues
like Taoism x' three treasures frugality
fairness and humility we can polish up
our capacities for neighborliness and
mutual aid we may be as gods but we'll
live best as plain members and citizens
of our biotic communities thank you
[Applause]
it gives me great pleasure to introduce
Stephanie Feldstein who's the population
and sustainability director at the
Center for biodiversity she leads the
center's work to highlight and address
threats to endangered species and wild
places from runaway human population
growth and overconsumption she is the
author of the marvelous animal lovers
guide to changing the world Stephanie
[Applause]
thank you Stephanie and thank you all
this has been a really inspiring evening
so far and I want to talk a little bit
about technology and environmental
protection because I come from the back
to the future generation in just a few
decades we've made astonishing advances
in technology we can all sit here and
watch Simone's amazing robotics videos
on computers in our pockets that we can
charge with the power of the Sun it's
pretty incredible it's things we've only
dreamed of in science fiction and it
really feeds this sense that someday
maybe when we have hovercars
the world will be different and
throughout my life there's always been
this deification of technology this
belief that technology will save us all
whether it's from our own mortality or
from the damage that we've done to the
planet but there is no high tech silver
bullet that can change the realities of
nature including that we're a part of it
and that it has its limits
technology has been amazing things of
course and I enjoy being part of the age
of information and all that brings and
there's a long list of advances like
solar energy and water purification and
so many more that are a key part of
mitigating the decades of environmental
exploitation behind us but technology
alone isn't going to be our Savior it
doesn't let us off the hook and it's a
tool and not even the most important one
we don't need to wait for technology to
save us nor can we afford to do so in
1970 Norman Borlaug the man whose
technology transformed agriculture
dedicated his Nobel speech to the topic
of how the Green Revolution was never
really going to free humanity from
hunger until the people who work to
increase food production started talking
with those working to decrease
population growth because the real issue
isn't that we lack the tools to solve
the biggest problems that are driving
the wildlife extinction crisis polluting
the environment and putting our own
species at risk we have the tools
renewable energy technology has come so
far that we can meet our needs without
fossil fuels we know that diets that are
more reliant on plant-based foods and
animal-based foods can cut the
devastating impact of Agriculture on our
land climate and water and we know that
universal access to reproductive health
care education and equality can reverse
population growth of course there is
still room for progress in making these
solutions more effective efficient and
safer than they are today but we don't
suffer from a lack of tools we suffer
from a lack of language we don't have
the social discourse needed to increase
access to these tools to end
overconsumption to realize the limits of
our planet to realize the cultural shift
that's needed for gender equity for
agriculture that supports all life and
an energy transition that's not only
renewable but just and we also need to
overcome the barriers of communication
and privilege that are restricting the
access to those tools so in addition to
those working on hunger and population
I'd also invite to Borlaug's table those
who are fighting for justice and against
poverty and those working for a future
where all species including our own can
thrive on this planet because if there's
one thing we learned this past week from
that report that came out from the
Intergovernmental Panel and climate
change
it's that we're all going to need to
work together if we want to avoid
disaster but it's been nearly 50 years
since Borlaug speech and even now many
of our movements are barely on speaking
terms so if we're going to make it to
the next 50 years we need the language
to understand each other across issues
to mobilize people to influence
policymakers and the business can
we need to think outside the capitalism
box we need to think beyond partisan
politics we need to acknowledge and
accept the limits to growth and
prioritize the tools that already exist
we have tools including laws like that
to protect nature like the Endangered
Species Act laws that could exist to
save our remaining wild places and
create a healthier more just world and
of all the tools that were
underutilizing
in protecting the planet the most
egregious one is half of the world's
population women are still oppressed and
harassed and kept out of government and
boardrooms now I don't want to discount
the progress that's been made socially
or technologically if I wasn't full of
hope I wouldn't be able to do this work
every day we are starting to recognize
how interconnected these issues are but
instead of fully using the tools that
are already available to us in many ways
we're still waiting for that hovercar
era to begin so whether we're working on
the details of policy or developing new
tools or trying to crack the code of
better communicating how to use those
tools or the urgency and solvability of
the problems we face it doesn't start
with technology if we want to if we want
a world 50 years from now that's better
than it was 50 years ago we must embrace
the solutions that are in front of us
and have been for years starting with
equality dignity dignity and respect for
nature and for each other
[Applause]
it sounds like there's some friends of
the earth out there well I want to start
with talking about it we have this
lovely photo behind us and you talked
about this quite a bit I'd love to hear
your from you on how a sense of place
influences the future of the environment
and our resilience well I think it's
attachment it's a it's a primary
attachment to place with distinct
character like I live in the former
North Woods it's a it's a forested
region this was taken up in the Upper
Peninsula of Michigan a little north
yeah yes yeah that's what you say that's
goddess country I I think you you know
you can't it's hard to fight for what
you don't know you know it's hard to
fight for what you're not connected with
what you don't have a sense of and so a
connection to a real geographical
location with its own character its own
spatial dimensions its own watersheds
its own plant life even if it's if it's
that tough weedy committed plant life
that grows up in the cracks between the
concrete I think that it we need I need
we need my cohort needs that kind of
passion and and attachment and physical
connection and also to resist just the
homogenate homogenize ation of the
planet the the stripping out of
biodiversity which you and your
colleagues are working against so
cannily and just the reduction of
everything to a kind of a slag
of the anthropocene slag so sense of
place
biodiversity diversity of places and
commitment to sort of envisioning the
life systems the biota the new forms of
community biotic community they're gonna
perforce emerge in this era things
critical I love that term Anthropocene
slag I mean it's terrible but it's such
an apt description for so much of the
destruction that we see yes yes yeah
it's a love of the earth and any love
exposes you to the risk of sorrow as as
well as joy and to behold what's going
on on the planet in terms of the
extinction crisis just you know it will
tear your heart out day after day after
day yet what's so remarkable is the long
term long haul commitment that people
have to protecting the wild to
protecting wild lands or to regenerating
I've been with bio regionalist friends
here in San Francisco for the last
several days and learned about projects
here of native plant nurseries out at
Hunter's Point you know with kids from
that part of the city bringing back
wildness to characteristic wildness
particular wildness to this area so it's
indomitable as nature itself and direct
connection with that indomitable 'ti
really infuses one with you know renewed
love of the earth I think that love
peace is so important in you know
our our ability to keep on doing this
work it's it's interesting one thing
that we do at the Center for Biological
Diversity is it so every year all the
staff gets together for a staff retreat
where everybody gets to you know see
each other in person because we're
scattered around the country you know
learn about work have all those
important cross-program conversations
all of those wonderful strategic things
but also a feature of it has become the
segment that we do we're different
people from staff get up and talk about
what they love and this is something
that started a few years ago and it's
just become a really meaningful part of
our time together because people can get
up and talk about anything it might be
the species they're working on or it
might be their children who they're
doing this work for and I think that
really helps us connect because
sometimes we take for granted that those
of us doing this work professionally day
in and day out are passionate about it
but you know we only dig deeper from
that there really is that that deep love
for very specific things that we're
fighting for yes what would you say your
what what being are you inspired to to
your work by well I think my book kind
of gives it away that I'm a lifelong
animal lover and it's kind of been an
interesting progression for me because
you know I was that little kid who loved
all animals but I didn't grow out of it
I really grew into it and as I learned
more about different species I was like
I love all of them like don't make me
pick one and then as I learned that I
realized that well if I love animals I
have to love the places that they need
to live too I have to love wilderness I
have to want to protect wilderness and
one of the things that's been
interesting to me as I grew older is
that that also extended to to realizing
that you know we're a part of this world
too and that compassion toward humans
and an understanding where other people
are coming from as well as really
thinking through what are some of these
issues of equality and poverty and
social injustice --is that we're seeing
around the world
that's all tied into the fate of our
planet and the fate of other animals as
well and so it's really kind of expanded
you know my my compassion and my drive
to do this work yes
no reason to assume a limit to
compassion I'm struck by the
inclusiveness of more youthful and
contemporary activism that you you you
are part of a synthesis now that's
linking all of those all of those
concerns this is a jump but I don't want
to neglect to talk about this in
addition to being the author of a
full-fledged book Stephanie is the
author of some very interesting poetry
which appears on the Center for
Biological Diversity x' endangered
species condoms packages and I wonder if
if you'd be willing to talk a little bit
about that campaign which is so
brilliant because it brings brings
population and an endangered species
protection together yes and brings
together that poetry degree that my
parents were sure was gonna be useless
that they know wind up with things like
packages of condoms with artwork of
endangered species and sayings on it
like for the sake of the horned lizard
slow down love wizard clearly a very fun
project to work on but you know they're
also a really important project because
as many people have noticed over the
past few decades talking about human
population has fallen out of favor in
the environmental movement but obviously
it's still such a critical part it's an
underlying driver of all the worst
environmental problems that that we're
facing today but a lot of people for
many reasons don't want to talk about
population it feels personal there's an
ugly history to it there are a lot of
different reasons so we wanted to find
creative ways to reach out to people
when you hand somebody a condom with a
picture of a polar bear that says wrap
with care save the polar bear it's an
entirely different way to start the
conversation
and a really effective one and that gets
back to you know what I was talking
about earlier with communication is that
we need to figure out what are the best
tools of communication today and that
changes as we've heard from our other
speakers throughout this evening that
that's not a static thing is over time
the types of messages that resonate with
people the ways that you reach people
change and the endangered species
condoms are just a great project to be
able to bring this conversation that's
become really taboo back to the
forefront and in a way that's really
accessible for people it's a wonderful
wonderful campaign one of my favorites
was cover your tweedle save the burying
beetle the classic thinking about
conversations and scale you know and and
resolving some of these terribly
contentious issues I I live in a
smallish community and I wind up going
to Township meetings and face to face
having disagreements about land-use and
just how we see living in a particular
place and so I wonder you know it's like
maybe the reason we Bank so heavily on
technology to save us is that
well-meaning attempts at social change
often go astray so you know how
important do you think are factors like
scale and locale in making the shifts to
equity justice and more sustainable
provision I think the other thing about
social justice is that it's hard and
it's a long process and that can get
really frustrating because these are
problems that we want solved yesterday
and the technology promises is a
shortcut but the thing that we need to
be aware of is that shortcut getting us
where we want to go you know and you
look at things like if you think about
we started with Norman Borlaug's
technological advances and what that
promised for higher agricultural yields
that was at a time where you fast
forward to now and I don't think he was
envisioning a world with twice as many
people where we still have massive you
know numbers of people who are going
hungry every day and the middle of this
country has been turned over to GMO mono
crops so that didn't really get us where
we want it to go and and when you look
at agriculture it's a great example to
get to the point about scale and locale
is that you know if we were thinking
about agriculture in you know more of a
localized
and diversified way we wouldn't have
this GE mono crop problem if that's
where we were going into valuing it and
I think the other thing you know another
metaphor for this is if you think about
technology as being a hammer it's great
if you have a nail but not everything is
a nail and I think we really need to
respect the the cultural and ecological
diversity of different places in
different communities and not strive to
create one solution that's going to work
everywhere but really to look at how do
we make change at the local level and
how do we create these models that can
be adapted as needed to different
communities yes real oka lies to where
you know I am very interested in the
transition movement transition towns
movement because a great many folks
anticipate a world where there's a lot
less traveling and transport and a lot
more local self-reliance local
production for local needs and also a
regaining of us of the ability to
discern between wants and needs and to
address meeting basic needs locally so
enhancing life in those locales includes
regenerating the surroundings the
natural surroundings absolutely and I
think that one of the other things that
we get
from local communities is more
integrated solutions I know that you
live in a community with a lot of makers
and you know we've talked a little bit
that in villages around the world
they're finding solutions that are
trying to address healthcare as well as
local economic issues and environmental
sustainability altogether and I'd love
to hear your thoughts and how that plays
into this bigger picture well it it
hurts to bio regionalism which for
decades has been saying we need to
regenerate local cultures and and to
reclaim some of the longtime human
endowment for health care natural
provision and tutorial relationships
with other beings so we sort of shorted
out there for a second are you hopeful
that that reclamation is happening yes
yeah I do I do I think that that if you
know common ground can be literally
common ground you know the the land
under our feet and the for in my case
the forests that that we love and
learning how to sort of use it and
inhabit it on a long-term basis I mean
another hot hot button issue hard to
talk about is carrying capacity and
which is something that needs to to be
raised in all our discussions of how we
inhabit life places yeah absolutely
that's the one thing with technologies
we've tried to cheat carrying capacity
but in the end is we're finding out
everyday now it's not a thing that will
succeed at alas thank you all
[Applause]
so 30-some years ago I answered an ad
that read I'm looking for someone to
work on computers travel and meet
interesting people and I'm happy to say
30 years later I'm still meeting
interesting people Thank You Stuart
come on up
Thank You Danica let's see I actually
have slides um there's a kind of a
reframing I hope going on today in
relation to holders and it's getting
over the sense that somehow this is the
whole earth of Stuart brand and I'm you
know sort of the founder and editor of
the Whole Earth Catalog blah blah blah
and I will say some things about what
people come to you and talk about but
everything since the Whole Earth Catalog
I've co-founded and I noticed this I've
looked back more carefully at the
original Whole Earth Catalog it was
co-founded especially with Dick Raymond
he died a couple years ago who ran what
John Markoff calls a non-profit
incubator one of the earliest Inca beers
in Silicon Valley the sign over his desk
said fail young I did a fair amount of
that working with him and then happened
to have a success and I realized he
really really was a co-founder of
holdeth catalog and if you look at me in
context of the reality of what it takes
to put out in this case a whole earth
epilogue in 1974 and that's just half
the people that worked on it there's
some of the rest of the half and many of
these folks are in the other room and I
hope you meet them later and even the
earliest Whole Earth Catalog that we did
in a garage up on skyline Boulevard was
a lot of people and then down in the
holders truck store there was a lot of
people originally the Whole Earth
Catalog was a subscription operation and
if you notice the lady on the left with
the braids there you see her again with
the braids to the foreground here
handsome lady with dark hair that's Lois
Brittain her name then was Lois brand
and effectively she was a co-founder of
the Whole Earth Catalog there she is
doing the books I was talking to her
she's here talking to her earlier today
and we were trying to remember how long
was it before we decided to pair
cells she said well it was about a year
before either of us got paid we got paid
for more hours than I did and she said I
said how do you know that we said I
wrote the checks and she is very much a
co-founder of that operation you go on
later with coevolution quarterly of
people like Stephanie mills were in the
thick of making a complex publication
with many editors domain editor staff
editors line editors and so on and then
this photograph in the lower left
there's a lady who was then named patty
feeling later became Ryan Phelan at the
age of 44 when she got tired of having a
diminutive female name and went to her
middle name Ryan and on it goes oh we
saw a bit of the hackers conference and
this was a hundred or so amazing young
people who were reinventing the world
and and got away with it likewise it the
well I was trying to look for you know
what's a really good photograph of
everybody on the well and there you have
Java code and cliff Acala or leadership
on the left
Gail Williams should be there and the
photograph on the right is actually
everybody on the whelmed that's the
servers where we all lived in our
virtual reality with our imaginary
friends so how did it actually work in
the catalog what actually happened there
with people and I've had occasion to
look at this just in context of what
people have come to say and a lot of it
had to do with just the quality of stuff
that we found and so still the best book
on learning how to draw is a natural way
to draw by nicolai t's still the best
book on learning how the fly is
languages stick and rudder we were able
to find these things
it was tough keeping them in print
sometimes we helped keep them in print
there was basic stuff on like from
Helens got hearing on how to grow a
sugar bush a bunch of maple trees and
then get the maple syrup out of them and
make that
at the same time how do you grow a wine
and make good wine out of what you grow
and viticulture early on this is before
videos took over everything there was
still the possibility of learning in
detail how to make really good
television productions or film
productions and you could go dad ask
that and people started doing things
like that one of the best of all
publications that came out at that time
from the boston women's collective Our
Bodies Ourselves was a revolutionary
publication up to that point having a
woman's body was basically treated as a
disease and by medicine and with the
women many of them doctors realized was
actually having a woman's body is one a
miracle to an amazing instrument that
wants tuning and they worked out all the
details of doing that and it wound up
being one of the real founders of the
women's movement I think to take that
kind of control or the tool of one's own
body so time goes behind catalogs go by
coevolution goes by and by by people
started coming up oh you're Stewart
Brandon you know I still have the first
Whole Earth Catalog and I quickly
learned that you know I straight up why
do you do very few those exist you know
I only have one and and then they were
describing I realized they were talking
about their first Whole Earth Catalog
but why did they keep that what ask him
what that's interesting why do you keep
it mobile mobile but then they would go
on and say well you know that catalog is
what got me the hell out of Indiana or
Arizona or North Dakota maybe and what
it was was a for them a window on a
world that their small community was not
giving them at the time or they would
say things you know it's really what got
me started with making guitars it's what
really got me started with music in and
it's been my profession ever since ever
I guess did the holy tell I really set
my life in the direction it went you
know they're thanking me I Billy I
should be thanking them because there is
this gratitude that goes on and what is
the gratitude actually about this is
what I've been asking myself I think
it's about people getting not just
permission to do stuff to try stuff to
take over their own life carrying on get
out the hell out of Indiana or do things
it was a encouragement to do that just
because here's as was mentioned earlier
by Kevin all these tools and you get a
sense of my god there's lots of
different doors and I can peek through a
bunch of them and some I might just kick
open and go try it and see if it
actually connects with the world or
connects for me yeah that one didn't
work but that one does and that one
didn't it lead to these other things and
so when Steve Jobs said it was the
Google book 35 years before Google it
was sort of the internet before then in
the sense of that there's this array of
possibilities that open out in front of
you and that invite you into them and so
I regard this as a form of conferring
agency agency is freedom and
independence it's a sense of I can do
stuff I can do basically whatever really
interests me and the Whole Earth Catalog
was focused on the freedom of the
individual what's the opposite of agency
the opposite of agency is basically
victimhood and one of the things I
remember writing somewhere along the way
in one of the Whole Earth Catalog says
now what's worth doing unmake victims
start with yourself branch out from
there
I think agency is one of the most
fundamental things that we can take on
in ourselves and encourage and others
mm-hmm and that's okay
one of the reasons I especially wanted
to have my version of YouTube to come on
shortly because when people ask me now
where is the kind of thing that
conferring skills and tools where do you
get that now I you get it from YouTube
and we heard that in in Kevin and Simone
session Simone has proved that we are as
Godsey might as well get bad at it know
that those fireworks are going off out
there and celebration of this party no
yeah I think she made that up and
there's a whole other level of YouTube
videos not just how to weld but how did
you amazing things and for that I want
to bring up Sal Khan
thank stewards really really honored to
be here well you know I just want to
give up for those of y'all who aren't
familiar a little bit what were up to it
and and it's really an honor to kind of
connected and because it was inspired by
all of what we're celebrating today for
for the past 50 years but for those who
don't know about Khan Academy were
nonprofit with a mission of providing a
free world-class education for anyone
anywhere and for the most part it exists
on on the Internet but it has a whole
life of volunteers hundreds of thousands
of people contributing to it
volunteering their time etc etc and to
get a flavor for it here's a montage of
at least what some of the videos look
like but it's much more than that it's
practice it's feedback it's its
assessment in whatever else it's sound
and
I could narrate it I guess I'm told the
humidity makes it feel hotter why is
this excellent question LeBron and you
can just see the pleasure he had the
right to privacy as such is not spelled
out in the Constitution of course the
word Liberty is things actually can
interbreed although for these two in
particular it seems like the mechanics
would get kind of difficult if this does
not blow your mind then you have no
emotion but y'all would appreciate
oilers identity as I as I mentioned it's
much more there's you know millions of
learners of all ages I was about to say
kids but we have people you know 80 90
years old who are coming here to to
learn things out of interest or to help
out their family across subjects and
grades this right over here is is just a
story of kind of that the type of
potential were were hoping to unlock on
the planet about six seven years ago
the Taliban take over a town in
Afghanistan and they forbid all the
young girls from going to school
this young girl Sultana was one of them
she was 12 years old at the time doesn't
go to school anymore threatened with
things like acid burnings and so she was
lucky enough to have a family that had a
computer so it she did something like 10
hours of tours a day but then every
waking hour she would get on the
computer and try to learn
first she tried to teach herself English
and then once she learned English she
got a relative to get her any reading
material she could get in English and
she had a time magazine and she found
out about Khan Academy from that and
then from there she just went from a
second or third grade level where she
was at
got her algebra or physics or chemistry
biology and she decides that she wants
to be a physicist and then she just
keeps going she starts leveraging the
other resources things like the MOOCs
that are out there and convinced and and
wants to come to the u.s. she smuggles
herself into Pakistan to take the SAT
because it's not administered in in
Afghanistan they're shockingly well and
that's when when I someone introduced
hey we have to help her get to the US I
I tried forwarding it around with
luckily Nicholas Kristof from the New
York Times also found out about Sultana
and he wrote this op-ed and what's
incredible and just shows you the type
of potential that that's starting to get
unlocked in the world is that after this
Sultana got political asylum and is now
doing physics research with one of the
with a Nobel Prize winning physicist at
MIT and so you can imagine that the so
you can imagine that you know this could
be happening all over the planet and it
is on some level these are all pictures
of the resources being used everywhere
and this was work done by other NGOs
volunteers probably the most exciting
one really in the same vein is Sultana
stories the one on the top right this
was about three years ago I got this
these these photographs and I got this
letter from the young woman on the top
right
her name is aya and then she said that
she really enjoyed the the resources and
I immediately assumed that she was
middle-class for her she actually sent a
video testimonial her English was quite
good she clearly had access to the
Internet but then when I read the email
more closely it turns out that there was
a group of engineers from Silicon Valley
who are using all over their vacation
time to go to Mongolia and set up
computer labs with internet and
orphanages and what you see there those
are the orphan girls in Mongolia using
using Khan Academy and Ziya was one of
those orphans and what makes this story
kind of like sultana story is that Ziya
has not graduate from high school and is
now the number one contributor to Khan
Academy in the Mongolian language and so
just to give you a sense of what at
least the video part feels like in other
languages I'll show you this Bhutanese
community capita in mean naughty mean
hands with zinc p-orbital wanna do
Zardari on out early on out duration the
moon to the moon the sultry skies
importance I watched that one I get lazy
so this is kind of the start of what
we're trying to do and and really just
with with all of the thousands of
stakeholders now Khan Academy is clearly
much much more than than just me really
in the same spirit of the Whole Earth
Catalog
empower every person on the planet and
and try to make education really a like
clean drinking water or basic shelter
and just a human right and so with that
I'd love to
[Applause]
the Whole Earth Catalog is so absolutely
everywhere I just love what we're you
know seeing tonight is that how much
that's the case
I'd love to hear a little bit about how
this whole thing started for you you've
been finance in New York and all that
kind of thing and yeah and some folks
might might know the the back story but
it my original background was was in
technology but then I ended up working
as an analyst at a hedge fund okay and
then I just gotten married my family was
visiting me up in Boston whereas was
where I was working and it just came out
a conversation that my twelve-year-old
cousin who was visiting nadia was was
having trouble in math because of that
she was being placed into a slower track
so I offered a tutor tutor her remotely
when she went back to New Orleans and so
I started working with her long story
short she kind of got learned finally
learned unit conversion which was
holding her back
so how heavy a mathematician were you at
this point how how heavy a mathematician
oh I was pretty in fact that's part
itself issue part of the motivation was
you know most of us in our day jobs
don't get to go really deep into the
academic stuff and so it was almost I
like to visit revisiting all of all of
that but I was yeah I was I was a pretty
big math nerd in in high school and
college and you're teaching there's kid
really really fundamental what geometry
what were you guys doing algebra well it
started with Nadia and this was yes
pre-algebra unit very basic stuff you
know one thing led to another and and
Nadia started to really accelerate then
I started to work with her younger
brothers and word gets around the family
that free tutoring is going on and
before I know it it's 10 to 15 cousins
family friends every day after work and
I would just you know my wife she or she
know I would just like come home and I
gotta go I got I got a calls to do and
and it was really a and the first Khan
Academy was I started with the software
I was like oh my cousin's all need more
practice and I saw that they had gaps in
their knowledge and I was showing this
off at a dinner party in San Mateo and
the host of the party I give him credit
this Wolf's car Arum's on he said you
know this is all cool Sal but how are
you scaling up your lessons and I said
uh it's I'm not and he said well why
don't you record him his videos and put
him up on YouTube I immediately thought
that was a horrible idea I said you know
YouTube's for cats playing piano it's
not for serious serious mathematics and
you know what the cats do not learn from
other cats playing piano apparently they
do apparently has to start somewhere but
yeah and and and and those that first
content I put out there I would tell my
cousin's like hey this is there for you
watch it ahead of time that way we would
get on the phone we can dig deeper and
they somewhat back candidly told me
after a couple of months that they liked
me better on YouTube than in person and
I took it as positive feedback and I
kept going and you know soon people who
weren't my cousin's were watching and it
in a very similar story to what we heard
earlier kind took on a life of its own
and around 2009 I couldn't focus on my
day job anymore and we set it up as a
non-profit and here we are so teaching
that's a little difference in teaching
welding I think it's it's not so much of
a show and then do like there's a lot of
sequential stuff you have to get before
you get the next stuff and how does that
play out the how do you make that
actually go forward I think yes and no I
think that's probably part of the
problem of how traditional education
handles math or frankly science is that
we had to teach it as a series of things
to know or it's a series of stuffin for
sure that it is that but it is there's a
certain art to it and there's a certain
and I think there was it was it was luck
frankly that the first content I was
making it from my family and so I was
very you know we've been talking about
being open to just showing mistakes
so there's there's a certain charm I
guess of some of the early and even now
where I would actually try to solve the
things in real time they weren't planned
and so you see me go down a path and say
oh wait that's not exactly right all
right I made a little error and I get
all sorts of letters from people now
some people who are you know adults
saying that was the first time that I my
anxiety went away because I realized
that it's okay to make like because when
you go to class everyone that you know
the teacher does it like it's obvious
that you just would immediately do those
steps where it's not even someone who
knows what you know you kind of stumble
around a little bit make a careless
mistake but then you fix it you laugh at
yourself so I think it you know I think
they're like welding or almost anything
there's a there's a art to it there's a
little bit of a hey you know when this
doesn't work try this type of thing so
one of the inversions that occurred that
is I think quite profound is you went to
class to see lectures and and then you
went home and did homework and all by
yourself or maybe with a sibling or
something if you're lucky and what you
did is basically arranged it so that the
kids go home and see your lectures and
then they come back to class and and how
does that work what do they do back in
class yeah this wasn't my idea this is
teacher started emailing me and saying
hey you know that was a really good you
know or a respectable thing explanation
of photosynthesis and now the kids can
get practice so I don't use my valuable
class time for that anymore for just
information dissemination I could use
that for more human interactions and
that's when a light bulb kind of went on
in my head is like gee this could you
could rethink everything you don't have
to have kids all tracked and you know by
similar age or similar perceived ability
you don't have to have every kid work in
lockstep it started to dawn on many of
us that and you know the Benjamin bloom
wrote tons about mastery learning but it
was just never practical for everyone to
learn at their own time and pace but now
it was now the tools are there not just
Khan Academy but the MOOC saw everything
on YouTube and so it was really learning
from the educators telling and this has
always been happening in humanity
seminars and humanities seminars the
teachers and read to you they ask you to
do the work ahead of time so you we can
be humans when we come to the classroom
but strangely in a lot of
type subjects it wasn't it wasn't the
case so you started out in stem but then
he moved in the direction I took I took
the thing in the French Revolution I was
reading a novel about the French
Revolution let's see what these guys are
doing on that there was a neat little
power thing you did well yeah that's
part part of the selfish motivation for
me is I get as part of my job is I get
to dig deep into things that when you're
learning it the first time in school
you're under pressure you don't have to
and I'm like I want to learn about the
French Revolution and now I can I have a
medium to say oh that is cool and I can
show that and hopefully there's some you
know people like that because it's not
coming from someone who just you know
has known this stuff for thirty years
that like the back of their hand is
someone who's discovering and we kind of
discover discover things together you
know one of the things that was sort of
a surprise for me in education so I prep
school and Stanford undergraduate and
all of that and there's I was gonna be I
was supposed to go on to graduate school
in biology because I did okay in biology
and then but I've been at ROTC so there
was gonna be active duty as a army
officer and I could have cut that short
and ahead with some kind of doc and
postdoc and all that stuff but I really
didn't want and so I did two years in
the army active duty where I learned
about training and training blew my mind
it was this you know total equality of
outcome situation where you will jump
out of an airplane five times at the end
of course whether you like it or not
whether you do the homework or not
that's what's going to happen and
insistence on outcome and then just the
forcing of it and I saw the quality of
teaching often by black sergeants of
just things like how to down you know
how to do a parachute landing fall and
things like that was just outstanding it
was it was they've done it a million
times and you could say well they're
really tired of it no they're really
good at it and and the the training just
knocked me out it didn't it was the most
important thing many important things I
think I learned in the military is that
that kind of focus on just getting it
right is an amazing thing to impart is
that part of what is going on with your
courses do you think yeah you know the
central thesis is right now we're living
in a world if I asked any of us you know
what percentage of the population you
think is capable of contributing to
cancer research or starting the next
Google or or you know writing the next
novel most of us will say well today
it's 1% maybe maybe with the great
education system it's 5% but I think
that's because we have some blinders on
on what's possible it's based on our
experiences where we would go through
the system work working in lockstep
we're all accumulating these little
Swiss cheese gaps because we're all
being pushed along at the same rate and
at some point we see a lot of kids hit a
wall in algebra class not because
they're not bright not because algebra
is difficult it's because they had some
gaps in unit conversion or it was my
wall is the wall and it's usually gaps
in algebra and it you don't even know it
or physics and it's gaps in calculus and
we are seeing more and more that if
these kids can fill in these gaps that's
what's keeping so it's really it's a you
know I'm starting to get more and more
convinced it's not just 5% or 10% who
can do these kind of be members of the
creative class so it's a week but I
think it'll be 40 or 50 or 60 or maybe
100 percent and it's almost an
imperative that it does get to that
world because you know we see what's
happening with automation and and the
need for physical labor as much in a lot
of industries or even information
processing and you know I kind of
imagined we need to go to the Star Trek
reality where everyone is a Explorer a
researcher a scientist an artist of some
kind how soon please yeah it's happening
faster than I would have predicted and
and you know that kind of leads to a
question for you you know with the
Stewart
what would the Stewart of 1968 be
thinking if of the world today what what
is beyond
1968 Stewart's expectations and what is
a disappointment for 1968 Stewart just
played we don't
space colonies yes Jeff Bezos is working
on that when it's glad to see you
surprise and delight that the population
which had been a major issue at that
points it was so steep is leveling off
and leveling off pretty quickly thanks
mainly to basically Our Bodies Ourselves
thanks mainly to women really getting
control of the reproductive capabilities
and and also taking on things like
writing poetry on condom packages how
can you resist that I would be grieved
at finding out how many populations of
wild species are in trouble they're not
going extinct all that rapidly at least
not on continents or in the ocean but
they're on Islands but just that the the
especially the megafauna
keep going down and a special personal
project is to try to bring help bring
all the makeup on the back so that the
whole world looks like it used to look
like which is it look like Africa
there's all these big creatures going
around and we've had some successes so
the it looked like the California
mountain lion the Cougars were going to
be gone or bounty hunted and they were
headed out there totally back now and
they hardly killed people at all
unexpectedly
they're just careful and maybe because
they were hunted for a long time so he's
you know there's a negotiation going on
with nature that would need a lot more
stem knowledge to really carry through I
think but that negotiation is taking
longer than I expected and taking on
climate with a level of seriousness that
it needs to be addressed is taken much
longer than I expected
put in 68 he remember I was you know 29
year old know squat and one of the
reasons I did the Whole Earth Catalog is
to maybe the way you sort of did some of
these courses to learn about them was to
you know I was saying I'm gonna help the
people doing communist figure out
to do all these basics they care about
they didn't know how a refrigerators
work they thought you could grow a
garden by just sticking a stick in the
ground and throwing the seeds at it and
got over that and one season and then
either gave up or they actually learned
how to do it well I was one of those
people who wanted to learn all that
stuff and so the access to tools and
skills was my own desire to learn those
things but you know 29 year-olds have a
intense short view of the world and one
of the great things about us giving more
older people around and you'll discover
this as you get older is your range of
not only personal experience expands but
your sense of participation and history
expands forward and back and more back
the more for it in a way and then you
start to get comfortable in the long
story and that's sort of what I impart
these days that make sense absolutely
and what do you think if I'll focus more
on 1968 Stuart if 1968 Stuart were
transported today if you sit he or she
were sitting in the audience right now
what do you think they would be focused
focusing their energy onto for the whole
earth if I was any good I was still
interested in biology I'd be probably
looking at microbial ecology and Wilson
gave that answer initially the wonderful
book naturalist about his history as a
scientist one of the best sort of
personal biographies of a scientist and
why is that you see there is kind of a
way to feed the planet that way a way to
energies what is the microbial ecology
is most of life on Earth and in our own
bodies for that matter and it has been
it was a black box when I was a
biologist in the 50s you know the soil
with the black box and basically
everything that was very small was a
black box they were just starting to
learn about DNA at that point but now
these things are becoming transparent
and you know metagenomics the ability to
sample any body of water and find out
not only who's alive in it but everybody
who lives upstream and things like this
and then get a sense of the genetic
variability and then any given species
population I was studying population
biology but we were doing it with you
know less than one eye compared to you
what you really need to know
so the lure density is coming on and I
think we're still catching up with that
density which is an interesting
situation for us I think and I see that
we're getting right up to nine o'clock
do we have the last word or two you'd
like to know you know I I just think the
the the leg the tradition that you
started or part of I think it's only
going to accelerate and there's a lot of
things to be a little bit wary of in the
world today but I think net-net there's
just a lot of things that folks that are
in front of us you know mentioned
earlier YouTube is in front of but how
big of a deal is going to be and I think
we are over the next twenty or thirty
years not just education being available
but this idea of unlocking this
potential which is going to accelerate
everything hopefully in a positive way
what about yourself
you're here let's accelerate in a
positive way let's go all speakers back
up here take a big old bow
[Applause]
special thanks to Ryan feeling and
dannika Remy you created and organized
this thing and all the stuff that you're
going to see shortly thanks to the
speakers thanks to you the audience and
thanks to the many in the audience and
in the next room and who are not able to
be here who made 30 plus years of whole
earth this happen thank you to all of
them and thank you and I just want to
remind everyone that this evening was
really made possible by a lot of very
generous sponsors who helped make the
Alumni come together to make this
program come together wired long now has
been an incredible support Ken and Matti
Dyke Wald Wan and Mary Enrique's Stewart
and Ryan King Gary Ostrom and Peter and
Kathleen Schwartz they really were the
ones who made it all possible for this
evening to happen so I'd like to also
say thank you to them
[Applause]
you
[Music]